hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast laboratory include
clinical benefits of rapid blood culture
diagnostics presented by Esther babbity
PhD director of clinical microbiology
operations Memorial sloan-kettering
Cancer Center we are excited to bring
you this educational webcast
presented by lab root is sponsored by
option option is uniquely positioned to
address the rising antibiotic resistance
crisis and is harnessing the power of
informatics and genomic analysis to
provide complete solutions to protect
patients in hospitals and healthcare
networks I'm julissa Morozov lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge as a window just click on this
green icon located on the lower right if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credit after the webinar is
over please click on the seee button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits now I'd like
to introduce dr. Esther babbity dr.
babbity is the director of clinical
operations for the microbiology
laboratory service and an associate
associate attending in the Department of
Laboratory Medicine at Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center MS KCC in
New York City she also serves as the
director of the CPE P clinical
microbiology fellowship program at ms
KCC for dr. Babbitt ease full biography
please visit lab roots comm
please join me in welcoming dr. Esther
gravity I will now turn the presentation
over to her Thank You Julie I want to
get started by thanking object for
organizing this educational webinar and
inviting me to discuss a topic that I
know is of interest to many of us in the
clinical laboratory and that is the
rapid diagnosis of our success so my
goal today is to make sure that at the
end of this presentation you as a
learner should be able to discuss what
sepsis is and which laboratory method is
available for rapid diagnosis as well as
describe the benefit of rapid blood
culture diagnosis on both laboratory
workshop as well as clinical outcome
because you know at the end of the day
there's a location that we take care of
I want to make sure everything we do
benefits them to get started I wanted to
start maybe with a question on to get a
sense of what everybody sort of knows of
about sepsis so this is a poor question
which of the following statement is true
about sepsis is it that a it's a leading
cause of hospitalization is it a leading
cause of inpatient mortality is it the
most costly cause of hospitalization is
it the easiest syndrome to diagnose or
is it all of the above and think you
guys are going to have about 30 seconds
on to answer the poll but I'm going to
keep moving and we'll discuss the result
in a bit later so so to just really
frame the discussion a little bit better
I wanted to tell you the story that is a
story that's very familiar to us living
in New York State and that's the story
of Rory sportin as you can see in this
image are very Spartan parents were
either on an NBC show that a year ago I
do two ago but very starting with a
healthy through 12 year old boy who
basically was playing basketball
in his in the gym at his school and fell
and scraped his arm his coach so that vo
he got hurt and so just put it bandaid
on his arm
and sent him home which which is radical
simple thing to them worry wakes up in
the middle of the night not feeling well
and so his parents set up a meeting they
are in appointment for him to see his
primary care physician the next thing
they go to the physician the following
three and since since an i or the
physician looks at him he scraped his
arm he's a little boy that no big deal
give him some painkiller and send him
home thinking that the the kid only had
like a GI Paul Dennis Quaid in the
middle of the night again very weak self
not feeling well so his parent decide to
take him to the emergency room at one of
the major Hospital in New York City and
the same scenario appeared in the
emergency room where the physician
looked at him a relatively healthy boy
with a scrape on his arm but not feeling
well so observing give him some
painkiller and send him home but he was
not getting better so eventually he came
back again to the emergency room at that
when he was admitted in the ICU and as
you can see by by on the slide that he
didn't actually make it out of the ICU
she was diagnosed with sepsis pretty
late and it's to come to the end he
succumbed to that infection so this is
one of the story that's really sad and I
think many of us can relate in the sense
that we've had patients who came to the
hospital and the diagnosis was delayed
for one reason or another in New York
State the story of Rory ended up being
taken pretty seriously so much so that
New York State became one of the very
first stage where there is regulation
for the diagnosis of success so it's
amended that every hospital in the state
of New York has protocol in place to
recognize sepsis and recognize it early
and I'm saying many of us are now very
familiar with this step says bundle and
so many of us have to to make sure that
when a patient could present to the
hospital
they and they had suspicion of services
that this is taking care very quickly to
prevent things like what happened to
worry for happening again right so we
can look at some of the results I don't
know if you guys can see them but the
results from the poll shows that many of
us think that sepsis is the leading
cause of hospitalization leading cause
of increased mortality
most closely and easier central to
diagnose tickles
the majority of us picked all of the
above and as we go through the
presentation we'll discuss each one of
these options and determine which one is
actually the correct one so um thank you
guys for your participation all right so
let's talk a little bit about sepsis I
think we use the word pretty commonly
but what is that actually means until
recently
sepsis was considered um like you spent
on that ocarina continuum and a
continuum we start with infection and
end up with septic shock however in more
recent data and and report sepsis is
really not so much a continuum the many
of this syndrome that we're going to
discuss sort of occur either
simultaneously or not necessarily in in
one after the other but two things that
are very important to know about sepsis
is that one you do have to have an
infection and because we have challenges
in diagnosis of infection they can
either it would be a documented
infection or a probable infection but
infection alone is not enough then the
second component of sepsis is the fact
that you may end up with service which
is which stands for systemic
inflammatory response syndrome and
essentially serves means that the host
does not respond appropriately to the
inspection and the combination of
service and infection is what we
traditionally think of as success so
publicly nation hadouken nation then
recognized first there's many different
on clinical criteria when a patient
presents to either the emergency room or
the ICU and I've listed a few of those
including an increasing temperature
increase heart rate or increased
respiratory rate or an increase in white
blood cell count and if you have two or
more of these with a high suspicion for
success and so this is some of the
definition that were included in one of
the more recent research on my review on
sepsis so if you remember the continuum
is started with infection and ended up
with septic shock but between those two
things we had first sent severe sepsis
and then subject shock
so the definition traditionally of
severe sepsis were sepsis plus an organ
dysfunction or tissue hypoperfusion so
essentially thinking of sepsis getting
worse then septic shock it's when you
had sufficient this hypotension in spite
of the fact that the patient was being
given fluids to to make sure that the
fluid resuscitation and those with the
definition in the very last on sepsis
guideline that we published in 2013
however if you fast forward a few years
ago a few years now in 2016 we have new
definition and when you look at the new
definition versus old you can see that
there's been a switch to make sure that
like the severity of success itself is
really well understood so much so that
now said physically fine as a
life-threatening organ dysfunction that
is due to difficult course response
infections so a life-threatening
infection in a patient that has
Burroughs now severe sepsis is not an
option anymore so that has been taken
out and the reason for that is that
sepsis is already is severe enough
syndrome that you shouldn't think about
it as substance that's not so severe so
we go from sepsis to directly to septic
shock and septic shock is still
considered to be a success and
hypertension but in emphasis hence we
put now on the fact that you have a
significant significant increase in
mortality when you are in septic shock
so bottom line the the severe sepsis is
gone when you think of sub sisters
remember that it is very
serious infection and it's
life-threatening so if we think about it
in late term if you have to explain this
location essentially sepsis is a
life-threatening condition that arise
when the body responds to the infection
instead of taking care of the infection
angels its own tissue in an organ so
your body sort of turning against you
and for me I think about it is
essentially there's an imbalance in the
way your body is responding to the
inspection one other thing that's really
important about success is yes it is it
is a severe syndrome but when you think
of ballad in terms of other infection or
the causes of mortality it's actually
the sixth most common cause of
hospitalization so one of the question
in the pole would is it the leading
cause no it's the sixth sixth cause of
over hospitalization however it is the
most costly causes of specialization
accounting for approximately twenty
billion dollars or related to sepsis and
sepsis care and I was in 2011 I think
one of the recent figure from 2013
called a twenty three billion dollar so
definitely not cheap and although it has
high in hospital mortality it is not the
highest and with the example that I give
you over a thousand you realize that it
isn't the easiest engine to diagnose but
definitely the most costly one of the
things that's key a bad sepsis is that
early recognition is super important so
there was a paper published almost ten
years ago back home are in the critical
care medicine that beautifully showed
that survivors from sepsis and septic
shock was directly related to the
duration of hypertension before
initiation of effective antimicrobial
therapy essentially the earlier you were
able to recognize that a patient was
septic the faster you could treat them
and the better they would do so it is
important for us to be able to diagnose
success rate it relatively quickly to
ensure that our patients survive which
brings me to my second question which of
the following laboratory tests is the
gold standard for sepsis diagnosis and
so the police
and you guys have approximately 30
seconds to answer and we'll and we'll
discuss the result when when not when
the pool closes all right so is it that
um blood culture is the goal syndrome is
it multiplex nucleic amplification test
are they single flex tests that are the
goal sender is it liked it or is it for
calcitonin so when you look at the
surviving sepsis campaign so surface has
been there's been a surviving campaigns
of success for the last about ten years
um and when you look at the more recent
guideline on die would publish in 2016
one of the first thing that has to be
done when a patient is suspected of
sepsis is that initial resuscitation
which needs to occur really within the
three hour but ideally within the first
hour and one of the lab tests that's use
at that point is Farrell acted that's
only to tell if the patient even to just
sort of put the patient in the right
category however that does not diagnose
sepsis because the patient can have an
increase on like that for other reason
so old patient really - likely then need
to be screen to make sure that - just
rule out sepsis and in terms of
diagnosis then the test of choice would
be you get you guys guess it blood
culture so that's the today - filled
with the major um test views for sepsis
but it's also considered to be on the
gold standard and I see that a few
people looked at practice selective
again is screening and multiplex not
which we will be discussing later in the
discussion although although I useful
not considered a broad standard so
according to the guideline of patients
with suspicion of sexes should get two
sets of blood culture and other
appropriate culture is needed for
example if you suspected that the source
of the infection was a urinary
with a urine culture and this needed to
occur prior to antimicrobial therapy
with the reason thing that as soon as
you give in to evaluate a patient that
quickly time it quickly sterilized the
blood and so a blood culture may be
falsely negative but that had to occur
quickly how to blood culture as long as
it did not delay treatment so usually we
think about 45 minutes as you can see on
the slide in the more recent guideline
there really isn't any recommendation in
terms of which rapid diagnostic methods
we should be using and primarily the
reason is that we don't have enough data
so I want to show you in this
presentation some of the data from the
institution as well as from the
literature that sort of support the use
of this rapid diagnosis for for for
ruling in or ruling out sepsis oh god
culture of it can you guys see me I
don't know Julie can everyone see the
screen it's just dark now
okay so some reason I can't see my
screen but in a assumption if blood
culture or it is the gold standard but
right now we have we know that the yield
of blood culture is affected by multiple
different things that includes the use
of antibiotic prior to collecting the
blood culture so we talked a little bit
about how antibiotic can result in
installation of the blood enzymes reduce
the positivity rate for blood culture
additionally you may have on the number
of sets that are collected if you don't
collect enough blood culture set then
your your diagnosis is not ideal the
volume and many of us do deal with that
we recommend usually 8 to 10 mils of
blood but we don't always get that
volume and
Oh pre-analytical pre-analytical
criteria that are sort of outside of the
lab the lab control but that effect
really how well this blood culture can
come up positive and I'm going to
refresh sexy some technical difficulty
just give me one second
for that so that's half Syria now so
there's many different methods for for
lab testing but in this particular talk
we're gonna focus primarily on blood
culture and some of the molecular method
both amplification and non amplification
method so the last question for us since
we are going to be discussing rapid
molecular diagnosis is really guys think
that molecular tests are the solution
for the rapid diagnosis of of sexes and
in this case we have free choice yes no
or maybe and again you guys are
approximately 30 seconds to answer this
so why don't you guys answer the
question we start discussing molecular
diagnostics when when I think of
molecular testing I just think about it
in terms of which one of the section
which one which sample are we actually
texting so one thing you can do which
would be solve the holy grail of
diagnosis for sepsis right it would be
to go directly from the specimen and
looking at the blood being able to take
that dot and do a test on it and get a
patient resolved within a few hour
that's the Holy Grail that's where we
all want to be however as you may
already know most of the tests that we
have right now still rely on a positive
culture so in this talk we're going to
focus on testing that is done from
positive blood culture although it's our
imperfect gold standard that's what we
have so can we now speed up the
identification of organism once the
blood culture is positive we will be
talking about pee any fish we're going
to talk about PCR and finish up with
multiplex gold nanoparticle technology
right let's see this call maybe and I
love that answer because I think that's
where we're all thinking that this is
technology that's really amazing and
maybe we'll be able to to really
I answer the question of diagnosing
success really quickly and accurately so
let's let's go move on and see what our
options are
for starting with P n equations okay so
peptide nucleic acid fluorescent in situ
hybridization so you guys can sort of
figure out why we don't spell this out
all the time and just say PNA fish it's
it's a mouthful but what exactly is this
technology so many of us are familiar
with DNA Pole where you have a vehicle
that can bind to either ribosomal RNA
from bacteria or fungi we use that with
hope that we do for micro bacterial or
fungal organisms and so on with peptides
or with P&A fish one of the things that
was done was the instead of using that
phosphate backbone that resulting with
repulsion of but it against the target
because both nucleic acid would be
negatively charged the backbone has been
replaced with a peptide and so three
things that are important with that
modification one is that because there's
not that repulsion when you're trying to
bind to in also negatively charged RNA
molecules that binding is much stronger
and unlike the in epub many company fish
products tend to be very short all of
these resulting in faster abbreviation
and explaining why some of this
technology can be can give you results
in a couple hour or even 20 minute as
well see in this discussion in the next
couple slides I want to discuss power
primarily quick session and the example
shown here are would be for a sets of
stage where you have to target two
options for therefore detection so
called a would be lets say staph aureus
and probably will be cool and negative
that pool so if usually sample that's
positive by dot culture and is positive
for Staph for you you will have
ribosomal RNA and plenty of it in the
positive blood culture at room
temperature nothing would happen there
will be no Co resins there will be no
binding so the first step in this
process will be dental
increase the temperature to 55 degrees
and what does this this allows the pull
to the touch for the quencher and don't
then become available for binding to the
target ribosomal RNA so now we've we've
dissociated the quencher from the
fluorescent tag and decrease the
temperature back to room temperature and
then allow the probe to then go back to
the larger RNA target and once this bind
then the fluorescence can be detected
and if there was RNA be then the
quencher be the probe B would also be
binding but since there isn't the causal
protein binds back to its point or
molecule okay so these takes
approximately 20 minutes and a
relatively simple so you have a positive
blood culture you drug you transfer a
few drops of the blood in a tube to the
only slide add some reagent to six sets
you do an incubation for 15 minutes to
allow for hybridization and that's it
you look under the microscope and then
see if you have green or red
fluorescence depending on the kid that
you're using so this is important to
know about pnac's is that as we've
discussed it's on positive blood culture
only so importantly you have limited
equipment that you need to use
essentially a hit block and the
microscope which many of our laboratory
already have that and even more more
impressive is that the turnaround time
is only 20 minutes and so if you think
about the traditional wave blood culture
works you collect the blood you wait a
few days if you're lucky you only you
only wait for 24 hours
your blood culture turns positive you do
a Gram stain in this example you have a
gram positive cocci in cluster and I'll
be the rub down to the report that you
are submit to your clinician in your EMR
and then you have to read a few days I
do a few days to get both the ID and the
susceptibility of there is also in this
case you wait maybe two or three days to
tell a physician that you had a
sensitive staff for use with the PNA
finish what you're able to do then is
you do a Gram stain and based on the
Gram stain
you do pnac's and within 20 minutes even
able to report not gram-positive cocci
in cluster but specifically staph aureus
or go and negative status and then wait
for the census to report to the
clinician so PMF age Advantix has made
multiple choices that you have on these
options for for some time and which type
of of testing you can do so for quick
stage you have the staff the
gram-negative end into a caucus and then
this candidate quick fix for that
product at this point again you see
everything you even had a make a Express
Express fish which allows you to also
rapidly determine if you have M RAC or
not and then a multitude of other
choices that are regular station of
necessarily quick fish so quickly
Shannon fish has been around for a few
years ago if your experience already and
so if you think about that and look at
the literature to see has this
technology had any impact on clinical
outcome one of the original study was
done by Graham forest and Kristi Johnson
drove at the University of Maryland back
in 2006 and this was done using
regularization so what they did was
looking at the impact of of fish and the
identification of coagulase negative
stuff only and based on the study they
could show that using correct negative
that regular fish you are able to
decrease the length of stay from sick
bay to fold a decrease vancomycin use it
and decrease the overall Hospital cost
which was a significant going from
13,000 to 9,000 additional study done in
Europe so very similar results
whereby the greater number of patient
were on appropriate therapy because of
the result of the PNE fish for 98 to 89%
you could also have faster the
escalation of empiric therapy and less
number of course from the clinician to
the lab because instead of reporting a
gram positive cocci in cluster or gram
positive cocci depending on how brave
you are with your morphology you were
reporting staph aureus or collect
negative staph and given the clinician
enough information to make this
similar study has a similar result
social intervention with the candida
albicans clinic fish and this is a study
from dr. Alexander and colleague at Duke
University showing that using Candida
albicans PN a fish there was an overall
cost of importation of $1,800 as well as
a decrease in antifungal cost because at
this point that you can use cheaper is
all if you know the patient has Candida
albicans as a precedium what's often
used as an empiric therapy of the more
expensive cast off from general order a
clinic and then to make sure that to
cover for resistant organism so knowing
Candida albicans allow for the use of an
effective and the cheaper drug however
not all data are poverty and be studied
by Nancy Miller from Boston University
shows that really well and in this case
they were not able to show any sort of
impact because this was being done in
the absence of antimicrobial stewardship
intervention and I'm always thinking
about this in terms of that riddle of is
a tree falls in the forest and no one's
there to hear it did he actually happen
right so if we spend so much money to
bring all this really rapid fancy tests
but we don't communicate this result or
nobody takes ownership of this result
and do anything with it did we actually
make an impact and in the case of Boston
University there was no impact at all on
length of say of vancomycin usage
because no one was really looking at
that that result right which then brings
me through our Hospital at Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center as the
name say we are a specialty hospital we
treat cancer patients and other
immunocompromised hosts and just to give
you some background just to give you a
sense of how a contaminated to your own
hospital inpatient hospital has
approximately 470 dead but we have
outpatient locations for us this
throughout New York City in Manhattan in
Brooklyn Long Island but as but also in
Westchester the surrounding Rochester
County and in New Jersey so we have a
relatively high volume of
- approximately 2,500 blood culture per
month I'm going to take a second to brag
a little bit about my hospital and I
should have put the right ranking where
we actually number one but this is this
is one of the Cancer Center you know
with MD Anderson where we always switch
places so number one and number two area
one of the best cancer hospital best
place to get cancer treatment when you
think about the microbiology lab we have
approximately 50 FTE and divided in
relatively traditional section of
receiving the physiology biology and we
do approximately 300 thousand tests a
day in it and three per year and as I
mentioned with approximately 2,500 blood
culture per month alright so we wanted
to look a few years ago at the option
for rapid blood culture diagnostic as
I'm asking and so we started with about
in 2011 so options it's in 2011 was the
traditional flow that we talked a little
bit about before whereby you get it
blood culture it was positive you do a
Gram stain and then you wait and
delivery biochemicals
we wait for culture to grow and then do
your senses so a few days to get your
final result in 2012 one of the option
we had was to look at PNA fish and this
is the regular fish what that did was
then after you did the Gram stain you
would do the PNA fish but because that
particular test took a couple hour to do
we would be batching so there would be a
batch done in the morning and a bash
done in the in the evening so that
wasn't always ideal but that was faster
than the conventional method where we
use honey you would wait and get your
senses down on in 2013 we were able to
implement quick fish and with quick fish
that really was a game-changer because
you would do it grunting and right after
you do your Gramps in you do your PNA
your quick pace and within 20 minutes
you had a result and then you were
waiting to your senses like you do with
the other
in when you did the other section and
then in 2015 we implemented the
gram-negative PMF say so in 2013 and
2012 we will focus
stuffs and cotton against us and in 2015
we included the gram-negative quick dish
which is eco light revenue mo and
Pseudomonas arisen
so in the next few slides I want to
discuss our
msk taste experience and we've had two
separate projects both has been done in
collaboration with our antimicrobial
stewardship group with Susan so who's
the doctor so who's the director of that
section the PNA fish the first project
which was looking at the impact of PNA
fish staph aureus co-ed negative stuff
on on lab flow and patient outcomes was
on led by dr. stone and so the project
was essentially to compare the fish era
to post fish era so as I mentioned in
2011 we're doing conventional pretty
conventional traditional microbiology
will have Gram stain positive blood
culture exam stain and will do
biochemical and and then figure out what
the isolate was in 2012 similarly with
the Gram stain of a blood culture turns
positive but then we were batching of
fish would do a batch in the morning a
batch in the evening because it took a
couple hours so it was not very it
wasn't sustainable as a workflow to do
it every time it got closer to ontology
and then in 2013 we'll do a Gram stain
and then do the quick facial right away
and then we put that result of the
creation instead of recording a Gram
stain rizal we were able to report
special use of Co AG negative stuff so
the study then looked at those three
different periods of time and how that
changed anything for lactation so if you
look at the patient demographic for the
three years those numbers are a little
bit different obviously we have more
patients in the creepy annexation era
I've an 196 we have 97 in the regular
station era and then 103 for the quick
stage there's no really different in the
median age of the patient included in
this study and just to highlight things
anything that's bolded is something
where there was a specific
different so of interest on there was a
difference in the gender so we had less
women in the post-renovation in 2013 and
we had more patient with a metal object
cancer in 2013 compared to 20 pounds
percentage-wise compared to 2011 and
many more patient will neutropenic
as we hold so just keep in mind all of
these differences when we do the
analysis of the data that we are so
starting with some of the lab work flow
so turnaround time is it relatively easy
thing for us to join so we looked at
that on pre peony fish versus post
punitive 2012 and 2013 and as you can
see this is statistically significant we
are in the pre pnac she took about 49
hours from collection to result compared
to post ena fish where we were from we
went controlling an hour to 33 hours
from collect to result so a
significantly faster identification of
what the organism was from a positive
blood culture the time to send see not
much change because the organism still
has to grow and we didn't see any
difference in hospital length of thing
it's just sort of bringing attention to
the team impression right so if you look
at that even when you get a gram
positive cocci in cluster clinician and
the antibiotic stewardship team had to
decide if it a contaminant or an
infection so we're able to sort of
record that information from the trout
and of interest although this did not
reach statistical significance in 2013
they were able to make that judgment
call that it was a contaminant in 80% of
the cases in a greater number of time
they were able to tell because they had
the correct negatives that resulted it
was a contaminant probably a callable
contaminant keeping that in mind then we
then look at thank you my friend use
right and what we compared here was the
duration and the number of doses other
patient cancer patient will have a
positive blood culture and if we turns
out that it was correct negative scars
with the staff aureus they could switch
them from Genco
nicely no no and if you can end as you
can see all the information about the
information is boarded meaning that we
saw some statistical differences in the
duration of vancomycin because at that
point then they can make a more informed
decision to keep the patient on
vancomycin or not and you will see that
the duration was shorter in 2013 the
number of patients with fewer doses was
higher and December's patient with only
one doses was lower
so everything sort of a trending into
the direction of better use of
antibiotics but because remember I said
that we had less more not less women
more neutropenic patient more patient
with him at logic malignancy we had to
do multivariate analysis to just make
sure that the difference that we observe
were not due to other component and so
in this table and this study also
included a couple of our a collaborator
from the biostatistics epidemiology
department so that is the magic ensured
that after adjusting for age sex
neutropenia and multiple blood culture
patient in 2013 was t less likely to get
either vancomycin because of the DNA
fish result so very encouraging results
when you you implementing rapid
diagnosis in the second study and this
was on led by one of our senior
technologist diane and then looked at
pre and post PNA fish implementation for
gram-negative rods and this includes
e.coli said no more and Pseudomonas
aeruginosa
so we implemented this in 2015 so Diane
went back and looked at data from 2014
comparing them to 2015 where you get a
gram-negative Gram stain you do the PNA
fish and you're able to report to the
clinician that your patient has to the
moniz club or eco light versus waiting
until you have close to two more testing
okay so we science study when you look
at patient demographics there was not
know much difference in age gender the
name of stationary so methodological
thorough solid tumor we even looked at
inpatient with a citation and I
and they have a pretty similar in pre
and post PMF Experian what was
interesting
we're so actually a greater number of
e.coli I guess you really can control
for what you're going to detect when you
do this psycho study but in any case we
saw more ecoli in the post PNA fish on
period but not really much difference in
the organism gram negative organisms
that are not detected by P in a fish so
a pretty consistent so the first thing
again looking at what lab work flow and
in turnaround time as you can see from
from this slide P PNAC it looks about 30
about 38 hours almost 39 hours from
received to the identification and this
was significantly decreased post PNH
where from we saved to to the ID they
only took 15 hours again positive very
positive data then what the ended here
was to really take a look not so much
out at Vayner antibiotic use but because
we were working with dr. Sol and her
group of IV pharmacists you wanted to
look at how often at what point did they
actually looked at the result to make an
intervention so this is what we call in
sort of the timing of the antimicrobial
stewardship team intervention so when
you compare pre and post from having the
patient on imperium to i3
it took them about two hours in the post
Vienna fish compared to 2.4 not code
size is statistically significant from
empiric to census so it's hours days
from empiric to to the time that they
receive scented since its susceptibility
it took them to print six days in the
post compared to three point four days
that I was the technically significant
and when you combine these two it took
2.5 days versus
three days for the timing of the
intervention when you look at the
frequency or exactly what once they had
that intervention once they had that
information to make a change
exactly how long
what did they do so you compare pre and
post PNA fish
there was statistical difference in the
escalation and in no chance so less the
escalation and much no change in the
post PNA fish which all ties up with
antibiotic usage right
so to summarize the section on PNA fish
and our lab experience as well as what's
been published in the literature the use
of rapid penis fish improve the
turnaround time to identification
antibiotic usage it helps inform a sdn
prevention the anti right antibiotic
stewardship team intervention it is cost
effective because you're looking at a
specific target from based on what you
see on the Gram stain however that's
sort of like the the other side of that
coin right because now some of the
limitation is that you have a limited
number of target that you're looking at
and there's some subjectivity of reading
reading on some of those PNA fish when
you have to differentiate between a
bright yellow or a dark green and so on
and then unfortunately the time to
susceptibility is still today because we
need to wait for the organism to grow
enough to set up two sets of senses so
we're going to move on now to some of
the nucleic acid amplification metals
and in this table I'm only listing
everything some of the more well-known
ones so stuff it has an extra mrs a
staph aureus for blood culture we have
the bio merrier bio fire Sarah Marie
blood culture and both of those as they
are based on pc are a nano sphere has
averaging and they had both the
gram-positive and gram-negative blood
culture test using this multiplex gold
nanoparticle technology and then be the
diagnostic has the beaded you know staph
aureus for blood culture that is based
on TCR and in all of these different
methodology also have resistant marker
and that varies from one presented to
another and so I'm just going to focus
primarily on the large panel including
the biome area
family and then the nanosphere Vera Jin
to discuss those a little bit more
so target amplifications on the right
you have the same array that looks like
it brought it bred the box and nothing
like the old the older style and then
the very gene where you have a processor
and a reader so the scenery technology
just to review I could real time PCR in
quotation mark in reality the essays
based on nested PCR and then Mel's curve
analysis so you do have LC green which
is 9/2 double-stranded DNA that is used
to generate a Melker for every single
one of the target and then based on that
male curve its Mexico of e.coli versus
versus staph aureus and may I'm sure
many of you are familiar with this this
all occurs in this pouch it's a simple
in and out and it's relatively rapid on
technique about an hour to run what's
impressive about this remarried blood
culture is that it has 2,700 it's a bit
it's a bit insane also of that's based
on on having both and gram-positive and
gram-negative as well as you so for any
grams from any blood culture positive
result that you get you would run this
entire panel regardless of what the Gram
stain is and so in reality with this
type of assay you don't actually need to
do a Gram stain so you could imagine
that you collect your blood culture and
so I'm bringing back that's that's all
that blood culture work so the blood
culture will be positive if you just put
it on the family and then within an hour
so you have a report of staph aureus and
you could you could even determine if
the sufferer was a Mrs E or not but for
the rest of the senses you will still
have to wait for the organism to grow
and set up your susceptibility
the very gene is based on this nano
practical gold hybridization way
essentially the extraction the
amplification and hybridization occur in
the processor which is the toll
structure on
the on my right and then once that was
done the reader would then take that the
cartridge and determine what the blood
culture was positive for for this era
gene there's a little bit more thought
into it so depending on the Gram stain
you either pick the gram positive panel
or the gram negative panel and so if you
look at the gram negative panel it has
the more common organism that we see we
also include ESBL and CRE markers so
that's that's pretty cool and when you
look at the gram positive you have the
entire carcass to start to strep but you
also have Listeria and some of the
resistance marker including McKee and
the vancomycin resistance if you look at
some of the workflow for the very gentle
culture and this will be similar for
this essay than the data genome that I
have put some example there if they need
to do a Gram stain to determine if you
need to run the panel or not or which
panel you should be running and this is
this is a mistake it should have been a
preliminary report would have staph
aureus or eco light on no jpcc and again
if it was an M RSA you say have to run
on the panel for final sentences when
you look at data and this was a study
from like a Martinez or from a few years
ago looking at the accuracy of quick
stage Modi and very genes
so within somebody about moldy but
that's another option and when you look
at the accuracy Creek fishing village in
the blood culture gram-positive were
very similar and including the range and
this is my primarily for Monica Kroeger
infection when you have polymer covering
section that becomes a bit challenging
expressive especially for the molding
additional study from Europe also showed
that when you compare very gene and
framerates to conventional method the
time to ast was better there was no
difference for you know the time for the
vodka should become a positive that
would still take about 40 hours in this
particular study but then when you look
at Gram stain to ast with conventional
methods you
approximately 70 hours before you
couldn't get your senses but was very
Jim and Saima rate you had about an hour
to to get the ID and then the total
results were done in 40 hours so
save-a-ho 30 hours which is very
impressive
so to summarize the not the use of this
large nod panel improves on the
turnaround time to identification it on
gets to an hour to two hours depending
on the panel that you use it improves
antibiotic usage because we can
implement ASP much faster if you know
for example that a patient has a CRE in
the blood it inform ASP intervention and
it is also automated and objective
because PCR you just it's a sort of
yes/no and so that you have to look at
it at an instrument for that rating the
limitation is although you have 27
target for example with the film array
that doesn't include everything that is
ever positive in the lab so you still
need to have other methods of
identification allowed for some of those
because must be must be so high that if
you have a really high volume of blood
culture and a lot of positive they may
become prohibitive and the times of
susceptibility still remains because if
they we need to get the IP the organism
to grow which then things needs to some
of the newer methodology that are
available and the one that recently
received FDA approval is the accelerate
signal system from accelerate diagnosing
and the cool thing with this this
platform is that you do get an idea in
19 minutes but then seven hours later
you get your susceptibility results and
so the acceleration of system can do a
gram positive as a gram positive Tunnel
that includes staff or a staff room the
menses cord negative stuff the
Enterococcus and trap but in addition to
identifying these organism
you also have sort of a a reduced panel
or of drugs that are commonly used as
primary drug for this organism and you
end up with the name I see similar to
what you would do with a micro scale
always see needs always Vitek instrument
and in addition to that we have some of
the resistance marker they also have fun
Candida albicans and colic can be back
your brother although they don't have
anti fungal marker or if it doesn't go
and testing down and then for the
gram-negative again the e.coli declared
the answer or procedural vector so it
can do more common organism and if you
more antibiotic there where you get a mi
see that then helps you so thinking
about is seven hours if you have time to
it to basically impact patient care
we're going to finish up with closed
culture and dependence so as I mentioned
this is sort of the Holy Grail right
that's where we all want to be being
able to take that specimen and do
testing directly similar to what
chemistry and hematology/oncology doing
and so at this point II to magnetic
resonance technology is sort of the only
player that is fda-approved for that
particular option so the things to know
about t2 there's no DNA extraction so
you don't lose target which is good when
you you're looking at success sometimes
you don't have them in your organism the
LOD and this relates to the candidate
panel ranges from 1 CF is approximately
1 CF you for me when you compare to
blood culture where you need at least
one hundred to a thousand it's of an
indirect detection of the target because
you are looking at the displacement of
water around the amplified target that
you have rather than really that
particular target so you're measuring
the change in the microscopic
environment so the workflow 42 would be
you get to make a sample you like with
their you remove the suit you like the
yeast you do your PCR and then you add
your hybridization and then detect it
and so the detection is this
interconnective agglomeration of
superpower magnetic nanoparticle and
Idid want to say this multiple time but
the technology works and there's been
enough study to there's been a couple of
studies showing that so this is a
current panel what I have albicans
ridiculous practice is crew di and
vibrato and this study that was
published in cid
showed that the sensitivity range from
one
CSU to maybe about 3200 that the
sensitivity was high and when you look
at the overall accuracy with about
ninety percent but it range from 96
percent C albicans to nineteen one
procedure broader so more study needs to
come to sort of support that and I think
there's been enough presentation at the
recent ASM that support that this works
well so right now you will have your
sample you do the t2 test and then your
heavy final report of Candida albicans
but does it mean that we're not using
blood culture anymore probably not so we
have to figure to figure that problem
alright so when you think about the
newer platform there's a some cool
things that are coming down the pipeline
so the acceleration show that you can
combine ID and ast and reduce that to
seven hours the testing directly from
Broad St to diagnostic does it is pretty
cool as well however we still need to
see study on impact on patient outcome
and those Evan just in a few but not too
many so we'll have to figure keep an eye
on those technology and see how the
impact ation camp so just to conclude
success remains an important center and
it is associated with high cost and high
mortality as we discussed it's the most
costly syndrome that we had because
about 20 billions on to our healthcare
system and he also has high mortality as
shown in diary stories so prompt
identification remains very challenging
because sometimes many thing can look
like sepsis from a clinician the
clinicians have to be aware but the
laboratory has to use some of these
rapid and sensitive Diagnostics to make
sure that once we have a positive blood
culture we are able to at least get that
ID within 20 minutes if you using pin a
fish or two hours which you're using
like averaging okay
those were the learning objectives I
hope that you guys now are able to
define sepsis using the more recent
definition and also discuss some of the
laboratory methods and the benefits that
are related to using those fold on the
record diagnosis of sepsis I want to say
thank you for your time and I would be
happy to answer any question that you
may have Thank You dr. gravity for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for if we are unable to get
to your question dr. babbity will follow
up with you via email after the
presentation so let's get started our
first question is with the increasing
number of multi-drug resistant organisms
and quick fish only providing pathogen
identification how do your clinicians
use the pathogen ID for guiding
treatment options without resistant
markers or acceptability that is an
excellent question and and if you look
at some of the large panel they do have
resistance marker however that is still
unlimited so the approach that we've had
Absalon Kettering is then using the
institutional antibiogram
and that's why we work so closely with
antibiotic stewardship team to determine
on what's the empirical be and sort of
what the escalation or escalation can
occur based on the I thing and that's
because we have an institutional
knowledge of how much resistance that we
see but definitely ideally we would be
able to get the senses not just marker
for one or two things but the actual
susceptibility results relatively
quickly so we can make more informed
decision it was like so many questions
great thank you so much for that answer
next question is do you run quick fish
on all positive patient blood culture
bottles or just one bottle per set
yes so to be again a very good question
and to be cost effective especially at a
hospital like ours where some time
patients may have I and I don't I'm not
joking sometimes ten blood culture
collected in one day um so our project
being to run the PNA fish on the first
positive blood culture for that episode
or for that thing unless the the
morphology is different then we're
running on another critique on PNA fish
so it depends essentially we do it on
the very first one that we that comes up
positive only and if the morphology is
the same that we will not repeat it
great thank you
the next question is how specific are
the fish peptides what percent of
sequence mismatch can they tolerate in
the target RNA and still give the
fluorescent signal that last generation
is a very specific question and i think
based on on option and Advantix data I
think they said by one mismatch at one
base pair mismatch and they will still
be binding we know that when you look at
the package insert they have known known
organism that I know to cross react so
you there is the specificity is not like
a hundred percent but those organisms
tend to be so rare that we don't tend to
see them very much for that that so I
think 95 percent above is what is what
we seen and when we do our validation
before we go like we should test we
rarely see we have actually a
specificity that are closer to 100
percent of 99 percent okay
- so much the next question is any
comparison info between MALDI cough and
rapid PA yes so I'll have to start by
saying so multitask on direct blood
culture obviously would be in off-label
use of the technology because that that
multikills technically has been to have
to be used on an organism that's growing
on it claim however many people using
that the sexy title for example has done
study looking at using multi table
directly from a positive toward culture
for the study that i quoted in that i
coded in in the presentation from
martini Enrique Martinez thing was done
at the University of Washington and if
you look at that study the accuracy of
MALDI was a little bit less compared to
PNA fish or or i think at the time they
did the very gene a thing and so it
works we've tried that it works most of
the time so the accuracy is not that
great and if you have polymicrobial
infection which do occur then your
accuracy goes down even more using
multis of compared to two very specific
context like tuna fish or of silvering
great thank you so much we're almost out
of time so we'll wrap up with one last
question and that question is between pa
fish and multiplex which one will you
recommend a small lab to diagnose sepsis
so I guess the definition of a small lab
would give you like the example of the
size of our hospital and we chose at
this point to still use PNA facial
versus the big panel because we we know
what the percentage of organ what the
what type of organism we isolate and
it's so simple to do exam skin is so
simple to do the PNA fish that that
works for us and I think for a small
hospitals not to incur that
additional cost of doing a panel for
every positive when you know for example
you have gram positive cocci you don't
need to do a panel that includes any
coal light I think that would be that
would be my recommendation and then we
do our molecular testing for respiratory
virus and with that you know that you
have no clue you just know the patient
is why that is suspected to have a virus
for example so there's nothing that can
guide you there though is the clamp with
a blood culture the fact that you can do
it Gram stain I would I would I would my
preferences for doing more targeted
approach to the identification which
then would include pee in a fish or
maybe like a very gene panel rather than
is super extensive panel but I think you
take into consideration additional
components you know like can you afford
it like how many positives you get to
decide of those what the best approaches
for you but this is what we had decided
to do at sloan-kettering hopefully that
helped I would like to once again thank
thank dr. gravity for her presentation
do you have any final comments no I mean
my informations there if anyone has
questions or would like more information
or data on some of the study that we
have done and some of the approach that
we have taken I'll be happy to answer
them so just feel free to contact me
thank you once again dr. gravity I would
also like to thank lab routes and
options for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through December 15th 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye